this is a production of Cornell
University
it's March 11th 2014 and we have had a
very cold winter i'm at the lansing
research farm we hit minus 10 here on
january twenty second and then had
several other instances where we went
below zero so Adam and I are out here
cutting buds to see what's alive and
what's dead and so I wanted to show you
how this process works and so what we do
is we use a razor blade and cut a way up
buds and look at what's alive inside and
so we're going to zoom up on a bud here
and you need to remember that great buds
are what we call compound buds and so
with image bud that we cut there's
actually a primary a secondary and a
tertiary bud and I found a great example
here for what's alive so what I've done
is come in here and that's what the bud
looked like I sliced it with the razor
blade opened it up and you can actually
see the three buds here the center one
is the primary and there is the
secondary and then there's a little
green dot over here and that's the
tertiary bud so this is great we can
look at the other side of the blood here
too and you can see those green dots
those are buds that are still alive
after this winter they all have the
potential to produce shoots so what will
happen is the primary will grow first
and as long as it grows well it's
unlikely the secondary or the tertiary
will ever grow if we move up the cone
here is another blood that I cut and in
this you can see that the center of that
is actually brown and so that's our
primary bud the primary bud is dead it's
been damaged by the cold but you can see
a little bit of green on either side of
that that's the secondary and the
tertiary and those are both alive so
this is what we do pre pruning if we've
had some cold damage is that we go
through we actually cut these buds with
a razor blade and look at what
proportion are alive and what proportion
are dead because that will tell us how
many buds we want to leave on the vine
because I'll know for example that to
balance this vine I want to have in this
example will be
thirdly live shoots but if I cut news
and I know that only about half of them
are alive that means I actually lead to
live six two nodes rather than 30 to get
my 30 shoots through the growing season
so in many years if we haven't had cold
damage we don't bother doing this but in
a year like this where we're seeing a
lot of damage in the Finger Lakes we go
through and cut some buds first so we
get a sample and figure out what's alive
and what's dead so we know how many more
buds we need to leave when we do our
proven
so it's March 11th 2014 and I'm in the
lansing vineyard we've had a very cold
winter and we've had some blood damage
that I wanted to show you so I've cut
some buds here and this is something
that we frequently do before pruning if
we've had cold events because we want to
see how many of our buds are alive and
how many of our buds are dead because
the number of buds were going to leave
on a vine well no the number we need to
have a balanced vine for example it
might be thirdly in this situation and
so if I know half the buds are dead I've
got to leave 60 buds so that I have thur
deschutes so I've cut some buds here and
I wanted to show you you need to
remember that great buds are actually
compound buds and so within everybody
there's actually three smaller buds and
this is one where everything's dead but
you can see a bigger set of circles here
that's the primary bud this is the
secondary bud and this little one over
here this little wedge is called the
tertiary bud and on this one when we cut
it open all three are dead so the
primary the secondary and the tertiary
are all brown nothing is growing from
that bud this year the second one here
it's a little harder to sue because the
primary secondary and tertiary are
actually alive here so this little
middle green point here this is our
primary bud it's alive and well if I had
not cut it it would grow into a shoot
there is our secondary bud and there is
our tertiary over here which is alive
too so normally it's the primary that
will die first so it's easier to find
buds here where the primary is dead but
the secondary is alive and in that case
the secondary bud would actually grow
and be a shoot in many cases it's not as
fruitful as a primary shoot the fruit
will come out a couple of weeks later
and so it has less time to mature
through the growing season sometimes it
won't be a fruitful shoot but at least
there'll be a shoot there if the
secondary is alive and the primary is
not but in this case we're hoping to
find lots of buds like this because we
want to sue on a live primary secondary
and tertiary bud this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at
cornell edu